>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELCOME TO "TUCKER
CARLSON TONIGHT."
HAPPY TUESDAY.
A QUESTION FOR YOU:  WHAT DOES
JOE BIDEN BELIEVE?
WHAT ARE HIS PLANS FOR OUR
COUNTRY?
IT’S HARD TO COMPREHEND THIS BUT
WE DON’T KNOW THE ANSWERS TO
THOSE BASIC QUESTIONS.
SOMEHOW JOE BIDEN MADE IT
THROUGH AN ENTIRE PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN WITHOUT TELLING US.
A PARTISAN PRESS CORPS LET HIM
GET AWAY WITH IT.
THAT MAY BE THE SINGLE MOST
DISHONEST THING THAT EVER
HAPPENED IN AMERICAN POLITICS.
YOU TALK ABOUT ELECTION RIGGING,
THERE YOU GO.
THEY VOTED FOR A GHOST WITH
A SMILE.
THEY HAD NO IDEA WHO THIS MAN
WAS OR WHAT HE MIGHT DO IF HE
GOT ELECTED.
AT THE URGING OF THE MEDIA, THEY
VOTED FOR HIM ANYWAY.
NOW THE REST OF US GET TO FIND
OUT WHAT THEY VOTED FOR.
JOE BIDEN IS ASSEMBLING HIS
CABINET.
WE WILL GO BY HIS CHOICES TO LET
US KNOW WHAT TO EXPECT.
IT LOOKS LIKE AN HR DEPARTMENT
IN A LIBERAL COMPANY.
THE REST OF US WILL GET STEARN
LECTURES ABOUT OUR MORAL
FAILINGS AND A GROUP OF PEOPLE
WILL GET RICHER.
IF JEFF BEZOS TOOK OVER THE
GOVERNMENT THIS IS WHAT IT WOULD
BEING LIKE.
THIS IS NOW ONE OF JOE BIDEN’S
CLOSEST ADVISORS.
HE SPENT YEARS AS A LOBBYIST
REPRESENTING GENERAL MOTORS AND
ELI LILLY AND PFIZER.
HE IS ONE OF THE PEOPLE WHO
HELPED LEAD THE ALIGNMENT OF BIG
BUSINESS FOR JOE BIDEN AS
PRESIDENT.
HE SHARES THEIR GOALS AND THEIR
WORLD VIEW.
PARTICULARLY ON THE QUESTION OF
CHINA.
20 YEARS AGO STEVE WAS THE
DEPARTMENT CHIEF OF STAFF TO
BILL CLINTON.
IN THAT ROLE HE HELPED LEAD THE
EFFORT TO ALLOW CHINA INTO THE
WORLD TRADE ORGANIZATION.
THAT TURNED OUT TO BE NOT
A SMALL THING.
HIS LOBBYING WORK.
THE RESULT WAS ONE OF THE
GREATEST DISASTERS BEFALL THIS
COUNTRY IN PEACETIME.
ONE STUDY FOUND THAT THANKS TO
THAT DECISION TO LEAD CHINA INTO
THE WTO, THE UNITED STATES LOST
3.5 MILLION GOOD PAYING JOBS AND
EFFECTS RIPPLED THROUGH THE
GENERATIONS.
IF YOU WONDER WHY THERE IS
A FENTANYL EPIDEMIC IN MIDDLE
AMERICA AND WHY THE LIFE
EXPECTANCY FOR AMERICAN BORN
MIDDLE-CLASS AMERICANS IS IN
DECLINE, THAT’S A BIG PART OF
THE REASON.
MILLIONS OF MEN LOST THEIR JOBS
AND THE SOCIETY COLLAPSED.
IF YOU LIVED INWARD FROM THE
COAST YOU HAVE SEEN IT
FIRSTHAND.
STEVE WAS BEHIND IT.
HE WAS NOT PUNISHED FOR IT.
HE WAS PROMOTED.
JOE BIDEN WANTS MORE OF THIS AND
BIDEN WANTS LESS DISSENT FROM
THE POPULATION.
BIDEN KNOWS THAT AN ARMED
SOCIETY IS AN INDEPENDENT
SOCIETY.
HE IS NOT FOR THAT.
THAT’S WHY HE HIRED CONGRESSMAN
RICH MAN WHO CLAIMS HE WILL
DISARM LAW-ABIDING AMERICANS WHO
HAVE DONE NOTHING WRONG.
THEY WILL BE PUNISHED.
THAT’S NOT SPECULATION.
RICHMAN SAID SO ON TELEVISION.
HERE HE IS ON CNN LAST YEAR.
>> IF IT’S A MANDATORY BUYBACK
YOU MAY RUN INTO COMPLICATIONS
BUT IT DOESN’T OFFEND ME.
IT SOUNDS LIKE SOMETHING I COULD
SUPPORT.
>> Tucker: GUN CONTROL DID NOT
PLAY A LARGE ROLE IN OUR DEBATES
COMING UP TO THE ELECTION.
IT’S BECOMING CLEAR THAT
PREVENTING AMERICANS FROM
DEFENDING THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES IS A BIG PART OF THE
BIDEN AGENDA.
THAT’S PART OF THE REASON THE
CAMPAIGN MANAGER IS NOW HIS
DEPUTY CHIEF OF STAFF.
WHEN A RECORD NUMBER OF
AMERICANS HAVE PURCHASED LEGAL
FIREARMS TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
FROM SKY ROCKETING CRIME
ACCIDENT SHE CALLED FOR THE
CONFISCATION OF 10 MILLION
LEGALLY OWNED FIREARMS.
HERE SHE IS SAYING THAT HERSELF.
>> A PLAN THAT SUPPORTS
MANDATORY BUY BACKS OF WEAPONS
OF WAR.
A WEAPONS BAN IS VERY, VERY
IMPORTANT.
THAT ONLY TAKES WEAPONS OF WAR
OFF THE STREETS IN THE FUTURE.
IT DOES NOTHING FOR WEAPONS OF
WAR CURRENTLY OUT THERE.
I THINK THERE ARE 15 OR 16
MILLION.
>> Tucker: SHE DOESN’T KNOW THE
NUMBER.
IMAGINE WHAT SHE KNOWS ABOUT
FIREARMS OR ANYTHING ELSE.
IT DOESN’T MATTER.
SHE PLANS TO SEIZE THEM ANYWAY.
MANDATORY BUY BACKS ARE SEIZURES
TAKING PRIVATE PROPERTY BY
FORCE.
NOT BECAUSE THE PEOPLE WHO OWN
THOSE FIREARMS HAVE DONE
ANYTHING WRONG.
SHE DOESN’T THINK YOU SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO HAVE THEM.
WHAT WILL THAT LOOK LIKE WHEN
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TRIES
TO DISARM LAW-ABIDING AMERICANS?
WE WILL FIND OUT.
THE COUNTRY COULD LOOK
DIFFERENT VERY SOON.
ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS WAS CHOSEN
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY.
IT WAS CREATED 20 YEARS AGO IN
THE WAKE OF THE 9-11 ATTACKS.
IT HAD ONE PURPOSE:
PROTECT THE COUNTRY.
MAYORKAS HAS A DIFFERENT PLAN
FOR DHS.
HE WILL USE THE AGENCY TO
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF
IMMIGRATION FROM THE THIRD WORLD
INTO AMERICA BECAUSE AMERICA
DOESN’T HAVE ENOUGH GOING ON.
WE DON’T HAVE ENOUGH PROBLEMS SO
WE WILL MIX IT UP.
IN AN INTERVIEW HE CALLED FOR
AMNESTY FOR ANYONE WHO ARRIVES
IN THE UNITED STATES ILLEGALLY
UNDER THE AGE OF 31 REGARDLESS
OF HOW HOLD THEY ARE NOW.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
-- OLD.
HOW MANY PEOPLE WOULD THAT
INCLUDE?
TENS OF MILLIONS.
WATCH.
>> WHAT ELSE WOULD YOU LOOK FOR?
>> PERHAPS A GREATER POPULATION
OF INDIVIDUALS WHO WOULD QUALIFY
IN TERMS OF THEIR AGE.
ONE OF THE LIMITATIONS ON DACA
ONE HAD TO BE UNDER THE AGE OF
31 AT THE TIME OF APPLICATION
EVEN THOUGH ONE WAS BROUGHT TO
THE UNITED STATES AS
A 2-YEAR-OLD.
THE DETERMINING FACTOR SHOULD BE
HOW OLD WAS ONE WHEN THEY CAME
TO THE UNITED STATES AS OPPOSED
TO NOW.
>> YOU WOULD LIKE TO SEE IT
EXPANDED?
>> I WOULD.
>> Tucker: GUYS LIKE THAT AND
BARACK OBAMA IS A PERFECT
EXAMPLE ARE THE OPPOSITE OF
DONALD TRUMP.
NO MATTER WHAT TRUMP SAYS, WHO
COULD BE READING THE PHONE BOOK
OR THE LYRICS TO THE BIRTHDAY
SONG AND IT’S ALWAYS BIG AND
LOUD AND JARRING.
BUT PEOPLE THE ACTUAL RADICALS,
PEOPLE SAYING OUT OF THE
MAINSTREAM.
YOU CAN CHECK THE POLLING.
THAT VIEW IS NOT A MAJORITY
VIEW.
IT’S A VIEW OF A TINY GROUP OF
RADICALS BUT THEY SAY IT IN THE
CALMEST TONE LIKE IT’S NOT A BIG
DEAL.
IT IS A BIG DEAL.
IN MAYORKAS GETS HIS WAY THIS
WILL BE A DIFFERENT COUNTRY
OVERNIGHT WITH DIFFERENT
POLITICS.
THAT’S A SNAPSHOT OF DOMESTIC
POLICY SHAPING UP UNDER THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
HOW ABOUT FOREIGN POLICY?
JOE BIDEN IS NOMINATING TONY
BLINKEN TO BE THE SECRETARY OF
STATE.
BLINKEN CO FOUNDED A STRATEGIC
CONSULTING GROUP.
BECAUSE IT’S NOT A LOBBYING
OPERATION WE DON’T KNOW THAT
MUCH MORE.
THEY ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
DISCLOSE WHERE THEY GET THEIR
MONEY.
WE BELIEVE THAT SCHMIDT FROM
GOOGLE WAS ONE OF THEIR CLIENTS.
BLINKEN HAS BEEN A GLOBAL
AFFAIRS ANALYST AT CNN.
BLINKEN FELL HARD FOR THE LEWD
LUDICROUS RUSSIAN COLLUSION
LINE.
WATCH.
>> HE IS DOING MR. PUTIN’S
BIDDING.
-- THE PRESIDENT’S ON-GOING
COLLUSION WITH RUSSIA IS
STRIKING INTENTIONALLY OR NOT.
>> Tucker: WHEN YOU CRITICIZE
THE FBI, THAT’S NOT YOUR FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHT AS AN AMERICAN.
YOU ARE DOING MR. PUTIN’S
BIDDING AND IT’S PART OF THE
PRESIDENT’S ON-GOINGCLUSION WITH
RUSSIA.
TONY BLINKEN IS THE BEST WE
PRODUCED.
THERE IS NOT A CREDENTIAL HE
DOESN’T HAVE.
HE WENT TO HARVARD, BUT HE IS
NOT A GENIUS.
YOU CAN TELL THAT BY HIS
POSITION ON THE INVASION OF
IRAQ.
THIS IS HIM DURING THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION CELEBRATING THE
INVASION OF THAT COUNTRY LIKE
IT’S BEEN A ROARING SUCCESS.
>> THE WISDOM OF GOING TO WAR
WITH IRAQ WILL BE DEBATED FOR
YEARS.
WHAT IS BEYOND DEBATE AND WHAT
NEWS COVERAGE OF IRAQ FAILED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE IS THAT IRAQ TODAY
IS LESS VIOLENT, MORE DEMOCRATIC
AND MORE PROSPEROUS AND THE
UNITED STATES MORE DEEPLY
ENGAGED THERE THAN ANY TIME IN
RECENT HISTORY.
>> Tucker: YEAH, IRAQ IS IN
GREAT SHAPE.
GOOD POINT TONY BLINKEN.
YOU SEEM LIKE A SMART GUY.
YOU SHOULD BE SECRETARY OF
STATE.
UNDER JOE BIDEN WE WILL BE.
NOT IMPRESSIVE.
IT IS STARTING TO LOOK LIKE THE
OPPOSITE, THE MIRROR IMAGE OF
WHAT DONALD TRUMP RAN ON IN
2016.
POLICIES SO POPULAR TRUMP GOT
ELECTED ON THEM DESPITE HAVING
NO BACKGROUND IN POLITICS AND
STILL GOT ELECTED BECAUSE THOSE
POLICIES WERE POPULAR AND REMAIN
POPULAR.
BIDEN IS ABOUT TO GIVE US THE
OPPOSITE.
MORE GIVEAWAYS TO CHINA.
MORE POINTLESS WARS IN THE
MIDDLE EAST THAT NO ONE OUTSIDE
OF WASHINGTON SUPPORTS.
MASSIVE INCREASES IN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS AND A HUGE DROP IN
AMERICAN WAGES THAT ALWAYS IS
THE RESULT OF THAT WHEN YOU
FLOOD THE LOW END LABOR POOL,
THE PRICE OF LABOR GOES DOWN.
THAT’S CALLED SUPPLY AND DEMAND
BUT THEY DON’T CARE.
THEN THE CHAOS AND INSTABILITY
AT HOME WHEN THEY STOKED FOR
MONTHS.
FEWER AMERICANS ABLE TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILIES IN
THE FACE OF THAT CHAOS WHICH
THEY CAUGHT.
ABOVE ALL, THIS IS THE DEFINING
CHARACTERISTIC SO FAR, MORE
CORPORATE CONTROL OVER OUR
LIVES.
THIS IS THE POINT, THIS IS THE
THEME.
LET’S HOPE WE’RE WRONG.
AS OF TONIGHT IT LOOKS LIKE THIS
IS WHAT WE ARE STARING DOWN.
IF YOU BELIEVE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS POWERFUL NOW AND
IN SOME CASES TOO POWERFUL.
WAIT UNTIL IT ALIGNS WITH BIG
BUSINESS.
THAT APPEARS TO BE HAPPENING.
HOW MANY PEOPLE KNEW THEY WERE